لأسباب أخلاقية ، يختار KCTV5
عدم عرض الفيديو بكامله
ولكن يمكنك أن ترى فيه المرأة تدفع
طفلًا إلى الخارج في يد رجل ،
سنقوم بإيقاف الفيديو هناك ولكن
ما يحدث بعد ذلك يتم مشاهدة الرجل
مرارًا وتكرارًا  لكمة الطفل
بقبضة مغلقة أيضًا تغطي فم الطفل مما يؤدي إلى
اختناقه وفقًا
لسجلات المحكمة ، تم تحديد المرأة على أنها
تيفاني هوكاداي والرجل هو تيري
واتسون هدفنا هو منع ومعالجة
جميع أشكال إساءة معاملة الأطفال وإهمالهم
كريستينا جونز مع  تقول
جمعية Kappa Child Abuse Prevention Association غير الهادفة
للربح ، إنه من الضروري أن
يعرف الناس ما إذا كنت ترى شيئًا يقول شيئًا
أعتقد أن المهم بالنسبة
للشخص العادي في مدينة كانساس سيتي
هو أننا جميعًا جزء من
مهمة حماية الأطفال التي تتطلبها
نحن جميعًا للحفاظ على سلامة الأطفال ،
هذا ما حدث بالضبط في هذه
الحالة ، قام العديد من الأشخاص الذين شاهدوا فيديو The Ring
بالإبلاغ عنه للشرطة ، لكن جونز
يوصي بالاتصال  g الخط الساخن للولاية
لإساءة معاملة الأطفال أو إهمالهم ، يمكنك الاتصال بهذا
الخط الساخن والبقاء مجهول الهوية ، يمكنك
الإبلاغ عن كل ما رأيته يمكنك الإبلاغ عن
جميع التفاصيل التي تعرفها
عن الطفل أو من كان معهم أو
الظروف ويمكنك أن تظل
مجهولاً في الشرطة  يقول شاهد عيان
للمحققين أن الطفل الذي شوهد يتعرض
لسوء المعاملة في الفيديو تم تشخيصه
بالتوحد وأنه غير لفظي مع
مشاكل السمع ، كما أخبر الشاهد الشرطة أن
الطفل يعاني من كدمات شديدة من الإساءة التي
يقول جونز بفضل شجاعتهم
والتقدم للأمام هو  الآن بأمان
أعتقد أن الناس يشعرون بمزيد من التمكين
ويشعرون بالمسؤولية هذه
المسؤولية الجماعية لرعاية الأطفال
وهو أمر رائع حقًا